salut rigo comme chaque jeudi et chaque
dimanche on se retrouve pour une
nouvelle interview face cachée d'un
candidat à la présidentielle et
aujourd'hui je reçois jean lassalle le
candidat du parti résistons un parti
qu'il a lui même fondé jean lassalle à
66 ans il est originaire des pyrénées
atlantiques dans le sud de la france il
se veut le défenseur de la france rurale
il a été maire de son village natal
pendant 40 ans il est aussi député
depuis 2002 sa deuxième candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
après 2017 où il avait obtenu 1,2 pour
cent des voix le principe de l'interview
face cachée je vous le rappelle jean
lassalle fait face à un écran géant sur
lequel défilent des émaux j à plusieurs
reprises pendant l'interview il appuie
sur le buzzer pour s'arrêter sur un
emoji dont la face cachée va révéler
différents éléments qui seront à chaque
fois le point de départ de questions de
fond concernant son programme et
concernant sa vision de la france alors
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube pour ne pas rater les
interviews suivante ainsi que les
présentations de leurs programmes et je
vous laisse avec la vidéo bonjour jean
lassalle bonjour hugo merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté mon invitation il est
perdant réaliser la sauve un peu vite
c'est un peu vite c'est là où justement
le buzzer vous permet de l'arrêté sur un
emoji donc quand vous le souhaitez je
vous laisse appuyez sur le buzzer et
commencé comme ça pour voir le premier
est magique qui va s'afficher jeunesse à
pied quand je voulais
c'est comme à l'assaut comme au loto en
l'occurrence cette année maugis vidéo
une vidéo va apparaître à l'écran vous
pourquoi je voulais faire un moteur que
tricolore
pourrait arriver plus tard il va arriver
plus tard on va commencer que du coup
une vidéo qui va apparaître à l'écran je
vous propose qu'on la regarde ensemble
et qu'on en parle juste après quel
serait votre première décision concrète
si vous êtes élu président de la
république
ma première des gens je recherchais il
n'y aura pas dans l'état actuel des
choses de premières décisions puisque
macron va être réélu dans l'état actuel
des choses les puissances financières
qui sont emparés dans notre pays l'ont
d'ores et déjà décidé et quand je vois
l'adversaire
le drôle d'adversaires tenant des propos
que je croyait disparu de l'espace
public français en face je comprenne que
les français soient très désorienté
c'est donc un extrait du 13 heures de
france 2 vous étiez invité il ya
quelques jours question assez simple
vous ne pensez pas être élu quel est
l'objectif est le sens de votre
candidature
c'est à dire c'était à double détente
c'est à dire c'est pas que je vais
d'être élu mais je disais si la campagne
ne change pas si le contexte reste celui
là l'immense fortune qui va appuyer
emmanuel macron avec tous les angles
nage tout ce que cela allait cours à la
transition cela sous-tend et celle qui
sort derrière qui sont déjà derrière
eric zemmour me lasse autre part c'est
que s'il n'y a pas de changement mais je
suis un optimiste invétéré sinon je ne
me présenterai pas
vous parler d'optimisme il ya aussi dans
votre déclaration de candidature il a
déclaré je cite nous devons être porteur
de joie touché au coeur des gens qui
sont totalement hagard comme après le
passage d'un tsunami pour moi la
politique est un art malheureusement il
n'ya plus tellement d'artistes c'est ça
aussi le sens selon vous de votre
candidature par rapport aux autres
candidats qu'ils voulait porter aux jeux
parce que chacun on est un peu à sa
manière ceci étant je crois profondément
que la politique peut toucher au coeur
pour créer l'émotion la susciter d'abord
chez lui l'émotion doit être quelqu'un
d'hyper sensible doit percevoir et
moi je le fais à mon niveau mais si
j'avais été un artiste ça se serait vu
depuis le temps mais je pense que c'est
ça la politique je le dis aux jeunes qui
nous regardent
laisser-aller vos pulsions vos
impulsions nous vous aurait freiné pas
c'est la gauche serait le plus juste et
c'est ce que je fais toute ma vision est
sûre le et sur le fond par rapport à
votre vision de la france c'est ce que
vous avez une envie d'aller amené
certains sujets qui se louent ne sont
pas assez couvert certaines thématiques
certains sujets est-ce que là qui vous
semble partiellement important et qui
est à présent aujourd'hui c'est à dire
c'est l'extrême financiarisation de
notre système nous sommes sortis du
modèle démocratique formidable que nous
avons connu des gens dans les années
50-60 ce samedi peut-être 80
certainement à l'égard d'athènes à
l'égard d'athènes
qui ne durera pas longtemps à je ne sais
quand même année un thème mais et les
femmes ne votez pas et les esclaves
étaient là peut-être aussi au début de
rome peut-être il ya eu dans notre
civilisation
vous estimez qu'on n'est pas dans une
démocratie aujourd'hui non mais dans un
système qui s'est emparée de nous et qui
est uniquement basé sur
l'action conjuguée de la finance
internationale qui est uniquement entre
quelques mains et qui décide de tout y
compris du choix du président c'est
quand ça se traduit selon vous cette
avec les médias le masi avant monsieur
bolloré homme détient une bonne partie
lui pas forcément du côté des démêlés le
maquereau il a l'air plutôt proche d'un
autre nom mais j'aurais pu faire dans
votre salon d'aujourd'hui pour innover
un peu je fais dans l'autre sens donc
oui moi ça me plairait que
monsieur zemmour il a peur de rien qui
prétendent tout pouvoir dire qu'il dise
devant une caméra
monsieur bolloré vous mériteriez de
passer le tribunal de la haye pour
crimes contre l'humanité pour rayer ce
qu'il fait à l'afrique et que tout le
monde connaît c'est pas un secret de
polichinelle
voici ce que vous l'aurez temps
à la tête notamment du groupe canal+
extra extra pour que tout le monde et le
contexte sûr qu'ils essaient
mais ils achètent aussi 5 comme des
identifiants qu ils assez excitant la
question voilà est très important pour
les lève tôt maintenant pour il faut
dire que monsieur niel de l'autre côté
qui est le germe de monsieur annoncé
reconquis la fortune d'un numéro vert en
france
soutien de monsieur macron à fort mais
il possède le monde vous imaginez le
monde j'imagine et boeuf mairie s'il
revenait si loyer niel c'est la somme
nécessaire une financiarisation de
l'économie c'est ça une place important
de la finance plutôt que et bien
d'autres qui sont que plus important est
que les sondages d'opinion c'était le
bouquet parce que là on vous met
exactement là où il faut on va peut-être
en reparler jeu la roue s'est relancé je
voulais sa fille et quand vous le
souhaitez
et on va passer il faut que je rentre le
moulin rouge vous souhaitez
nous et pourtant j'ai d'autres choses
suivent leur honneur on essaiera du jour
toujours cerné format qu'on a nous sûr
sur youtube mais concrètement en
l'occurrence c'est un et mozilla un
journal on va avoir un extrait d'un
article de presse on va le lire ensemble
et ensuite on va pouvoir en discuter
j'ai fait le bon choix joue
effectivement on est donc c'est un
article de sud ouest qui date du 15
avril 2006 vous le voyez ce titre le
crétin a été plus malin crétins entre
guillemets
c'est en fait un marché qui a été publié
au lendemain d'un événement central dans
votre vie et votre engagement politique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler
d'abord j'ai l'aï veya jeu tôt s'adresse
à je veux trouve d'argent contexte que
j'aime beaucoup et que je crois
reconnaître dans les pyrénées
et c'était relatif à la déclaration de
la secrétaire
d'état de l'époque du gouvernement
du gouvernement raffarin je pense qu'ils
savent eux les gigots et qui avait
déclaré nous connaissions le côté des
alpes maintenant nous avons vu que je
t'aime des pyrénées de quoi on parle ici
quand on parle de par le 39e jour de
gênes vous avez obtenu ce que vous
vouliez qu'est ce que vous vouliez en
2006 je voulais garder l'usiné toyal
dans ma vallée de l'allier a chiffré la
souris dans les pires des automatique
lorsque
alcan aluminium canada cinq cent
cinquante années de salariés dans le
monde groupe canadien a décidé de fermer
juste là des rejeté lui aussi général
j'en ai maintenant aussi départementale
j'étais dévastée par la déception
j'avais été élu pour revitaliser cette
vallée donc j'ai trouvée un soir par
hasard dans l'avion le pdg d'alc à
juliet beaucoup parler et à 5 heures du
matin il m'a dit je venais groupe
japonais vous devriez le voir j'ai
emprunté mise à jour un copain j'ai été
voir ce groupe et ça s'est passé ils
étaient cent des numéros heure là la
peinture métallisée qui permet les la
peinture métallisée des bagnoles et la
poudre à fusil exocet et donc pour
bientôt mais si on parle pour avoir bien
besoin tout le contexte de d'une grève
de la faim que vous avez fait contre la
fermeture de l'usiné toyal donc dans les
pyrénées est ce donc que cette
entreprise qui faisait rage près de 30
150 salariés dans les villages alentour
pg poser si vous permettez toujours des
actes qui avait une libation car la très
importante parce que c'était la fin de
cette vallée d'aspe
perdre comme ça une centaine d'ouvriers
la pharmacie allait fermer tout ce qui
restait fermé mais en même temps la
france perd dès 400 mille entreprises il
y en avait parlé avec le président
chirac et j'ai vu sur le téléphone au
téléphone dans les derniers jours la
grève j'avais d'ailleurs je le vis le
plus fréquemment et à ce moment là du
coup il est écrit que vous aviez été le
plus malin parce que vous aviez réussi à
remporter cette bataille contre la
fermeture à l'époque de cette de cette
usine
l'article vous de zinder comme le
premier élu sous la vème république à
avoir fait une grève de la faim et à
mettre votre ville certes pas sans péril
pour une cause de votre côté vous parler
de cet événement comme de la chose dont
vous êtes le plus fier l'une des choses
vous êtes le plus fier dans votre vie
mais aujourd'hui j'avais encore
certaines séquelles physiques de tel de
telles choses et je sais mais c'était à
refaire vous le referiez et que lorsque
vous voyez ce type d'engagement dans un
cadre politique oui je ne referais
par contre je recommanderais à ceux qui
pourraient être tentés de le faire parce
que pour moi ça s'est un peu calmé mais
pendant longtemps beaucoup ont voulu
imiter je leur disais je te jette
aujourd'hui
réfléchissez très très bien vous voyez
c'est vraiment le jeu en vaut la
chandelle
parce que c'est un quitte ou double il
en valait la chandelle ici mais oui et
en plus beau jeu c'était la mort d'une
volée mais c'était la mort de
l'industrie en france c'est justement
une question que j'allais vous poser
c'est que vous proposez en 2017 de
nationaliser certaines entreprises en
partie certaines entreprises pour
qu'elles restent des entreprises
françaises est-ce que c'est toujours
quelque chose dans votre programme cette
idée de nationaliser des entreprises si
elles sont en difficulté ah oui bon je
pars de chez edf mais je pense qu'il
faut nationaliser
d'une manière générale touche qui est
régalé il paraît que vous les autoroutes
parce que ça rapporte et vous souhaitez
que ça appartiennent à nouveau à l'état
on va passer à la question suivante je
vous laisse donc arrêter les la roue des
syndicats n'a observé mesure de
l'avancée de leur vie va finir par
arriver chance bien finir par tourner
j'ai toujours été là
[Musique]
après l'essai en l'occurrence un
chronomètre cette année magique le
candidat
ici de tous les candidats il passe est
en fait un chronomètre vous allez avoir
une minute pour répondre à un maximum de
questions l'idée étant d'en savoir plus
sur votre programme sur votre vision de
la france au-delà des autres sujets
qu'on aborde dans le cadre de cet
échange il va falloir répondre par oui
ou par non donc ça à chacune de ces
questions on va essayer d'en faire un
maximum pour mieux comprendre votre
programme est ce que vous êtes prêts
on va on va voir ça doit-on supprimé le
permis à points
les soldats français doivent-ils rester
au mali
non faut-il rétablir le service
militaire oui la france doit elle
quitter l'otan oui le vote blanc doit-il
être reconnu oui faut-il légaliser le
cannabis oui êtes vous abonnés à netflix
je peux
je suis et moi très bon vous cassez pas
totalement inséré des films faut-il
interdire la chasse à courre
là tout cas pas les chefs traditionnels
la chasse à clous que je pense que l'on
peut voir mais c'est une tradition
française la corse devrait-elle être
indépendante non je crois que les biens
comme que des boîtes ont boycotté la
coupe du monde au qatar
doit-on sortir du nucléaire en france
faut-il rétablir l'uniforme à l'école
non faut-il abc le droit de vote à 16
ans non je rate il une parité hommes
femmes dans votre gouvernement oui
faut-il diminuer le nombre de députés de
sénateurs en france et on et vous ça va
faire un certain nombre de questions et
je vous laisse vous appuyez
vous aviez est en train de s'arrêter on
est sur un et mogi bulle de discussion
vous allez voir après réflexion élevé
chez soi de discussions de réflexions
les deux peut-être déjà vu au juste
comme ça vous allez voir apparaître une
phrase à l'écran c'est une phrase qui a
été prononcé par un autre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
je propose d'abord de la lira vote pour
commencer oui c'est le coeur d un
communiste qui s'appelle
sel oui j'avais trouvé directement donc
on lit à votre pourtant on est un bon
vin une bonne heure de jeu diom c'est la
gastronomie française le meilleur moyen
de la défendre c'est de permettre aux
français d'y avoir accès a fait faire un
bond de 2 points ce qui vaut mieux quand
on parle vrai et sans fioritures et
quand on dit ce qu'on a au fond de son
coeur eh bien on touche deux
le supérieur qu'est ce qui fait que
cette facette phrase vous parle on sait
que vous parlez si beaucoup de la
question de la culture en france c'est
un sujet que vous évoquez beaucoup du
fait aussi de votre parcours est ce que
vous considérez que la gastronomie
française est en péril aujourd'hui ça
pose forcément la question de
l'agriculture oui bien sûr mmmmh de la
langue française la langue française
entame très très enclencher
la marche en a pas l'air de préoccuper
vraiment nous sommes perdus peu plus
chez les québécois par exemple ggyc et
moi je connais très bien avec les pour
les hommes je vous ai déjà indiqué mais
ça
parle plus un certain nombre de pays
d'afrique
que cela nous parle à nous donc je crois
qu'il faut effectivement pas consommer
sans modération l'agglo stone quand est
ce qu'on défend la culture française
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous proposez
concrètement en termes de mesures pour
justement protéger la culture française
dans la situation actuelle
d'abord il faut là la reprenne un
gaucher des reçus et l'inscrire l'âge un
projet plus large que j'ai appelé
campagne de france une grande cause
nationale
cette affaire une grande cause nationale
comme on l'avait fait parfois pour
d'autres et il fallait le solder par un
référendum de façon à ce que le 16e
arrondissement participe aussi cheveux
que ce débat soit partagée de tous pour
l'unss pour dans l'esprit de quelques
heures les campagnes des milieux ruraux
sont trois mâts qui goûte au pays on dit
il ya quarante ans de bestioles et puis
ça nous coûterait pas cher mirande et
c'est là que réside je crois le plus
formidable gisement d'emplois de 30 ans
à venir et concrètement en termes de
mesure se traduit par quoi du coup cette
priorité la priorité ça se traduit par
le fait que je vais être trois à quatre
milliards par an pendant mon mandat mais
spécifiquement au niveau de l'état gelé
retirerait à la contribution que la
france apporte aux pays européens
qui est de l'ordre de fait 4 ou 5
milliards c'est pas le but de les amener
son parti et il faut revoir totalement
de butembo la
la bac ok la pac c'est donc la politique
agricole commune qui est en place
aujourd'hui à l'échelle de l'union
européenne est favorite il faut ensuite
facilité grâce aux centrales
intervention de l'état via le préfet ses
services que j'ai vu quand j'étais jeune
mère très efficace un jeune à
s'installer parce que c'est très
difficile de reprendre une exploitation
agricole il faut d'abord
convaincre son entourage parfois sa
famille suite il faut dédommager les
frères et soeurs qui ont décidé de faire
autre chose soit ils sont tombés sur des
compagnons et compagnes de vie qui
s'imaginent que ça vaut des millions
puis ensuite il ya un plan
d'investissements souvent même pour le
petite exploitation familiale on va
passer à la question suivante pour
violence du coup la roue je vous laisse
l'arrêter
et ça va s'arrêter sur
pourquoi une carte en l'occurrence vous
allez voir s'afficher une carte je vous
laisse la découvrir ma pouvoir en parler
assez bon tour de france c'est votre
tour de france effectivement c'est le
parti des plus blasés qui avait sauté à
l'eau au milieu la banque touvois loire
jusqu'à paris bon je fais d'autres la
normande est ce que vous avez fait un
tour de france en 2013 un tour de france
à la rencontre des français 5000 km à
psion neuf peut arriver là parce qu'en
fait le calcul après un bon mois comme
je dois me dépanner km tous les shows
mais quelqu'un a testé quatre stagiaires
qui ont refait les calculs ces
stagiaires qui ont fait le coup on fait
le calcul qu'est-ce que quelles sont les
grandes leçons que vous en tirez de ce
tour de france
je pense que les français avaient déjà
enfin percevez
présenter ce qui ce qui était attendu se
passer c'est à dire
fait que le système
confisquer les plus grandes
l'argent dans de plus grandes
proportions
seguin d'antoine qui est de facto un
appauvrissement de l'espace public et
des services publics que les hôpitaux
fermés et pas tout dit a cédé 0,6 et
pour bien comprendre ce que vous parlez
de cette déconnexion de cette
financiarisation de l'économie et c'est
là le modèle que vous imaginez pour
comprendre ce que vous en parlez
beaucoup c'est quoi c'est un modèle qui
reste dans un cadre d'un modèle
capitaliste ou alors est-ce qu'on sort
du capitalisme quel est le modèle que
vous imaginez pour une société idéale
selon en a connu de l'urss et un avis le
manque de livres à gagner contre la
dictature
aujourd'hui la dictature on ne l'a pas
vu venir il n'y avait pas d'armes et aux
frontières il ré pas dimanche et
oriflammes cas quand au vent tandis
qu'une voix nasillarde vos
cris et depuis ajaccio puis aujourd'hui
mais ça s'est trouvée est posée si
demain nous nous sommes laissés avoir
d'abord les politiques et vous pensez
qu'on est en dictature aujourd'hui c'est
vrai en termes un homme trop fort non
non non une dictature très organisé les
spectateurs vous pourriez dire justement
ce que vous dites actuellement donc un
dictature je sens que je vais suivre dès
qu on aura vu très suivi mes fils l'ont
dit à ma fille le tout filmé mais je le
pays et je vais rester à 0,5
il ya bien un mediapart qui va me
trouver
des poux sur la tête et puis je reste
zen vous avez été accusé d'agression
sexuelle par exemple juste à des
enquêtes de plusieurs médias je vais te
donnant chair d'ailleurs j'étais dans
certaines personnes ont dit voilà je
pense que là une plainte en justice en
l'occurrence est l'un des méchas des
sapeurs- il a toujours marché augmenter
autour de 2% j'imaginais mais j'étais
psychopathe
qui était très dangereux très
intelligent photo dangereux ça vienne
tout gâcher bayrou avec qui j'étais
prêté donc le plus le pourra donner un
peu de contexte éviter au modem qui est
le parti de françois bayrou qu'un parti
centriste proche aujourd'hui didier
manier le d'emmanuel mâcon et ils vous
considèrent aujourd'hui être la cible du
coup de parc de l'est pas que 2 mai
mais ce n'est la cible c'est toujours
pareil c'est pas de une organisation
maléfique comme ça c'est des intérêts
convergents qui font que cela créé des
alliances convergentes et aujourd'hui
toutes les puissances
convergent vers
le même sur l'oeil noir et quand on
casse ce système que vous évoquez selon
vous comment est-ce qu'on casse un tel
système un résistant c'est ce que je
fais a créé le mouvement
résistants qui va se prononcer au au
présent et remise à chaque fois que ça
ne vous paraît pas convenable non j'y
lis ce matin non à france inter pour une
interview ça m'aurait bien aimé j'aurais
bien aimé france intérêts de ma radio de
prédilection pendant des années mais il
ne me trompe pas
au débat avec les candidats ils ne
savent même pas encore qui seront les
candidats les gens déjà dit qu'il
inviterait 17 oui candidats avec
lesquels j'ai deux prises la république
pourraient être amenés à débattre
on avait ça qu'ils ont sonné là c'est
clair c'est la question est justement
que vous évoquez que vous évoquez
beaucoup mais mais sûr mais sur la
sortie de ce système là vous parlez vous
de résistance via ses prises de paroles
que vous avez d'avoir le verbe et
la plume parce que ryan trouver le mieux
pour
toucher au coeur a chuté c'est une
attitude il faut avoir et qui sera la
plus cohérente d'autant bout expliqué au
fur et à mesure ensuite je je veux
reconstruire l'état les temps a été un
symbole majeur on a besoin de ces morts
en politique il faut un symbole est
l'outil il sera à la disposition du
président chef d'état et ensuite il faut
recréer une organisation territoriale à
partir de la commune on va passer à
question suivante et je vous laisse
encore une fois arrêté le avec le buzzer
une question était pour décaler la
pizza pino un
cadeau cinq ados d'air ce cadeau à
chaque fois pour tous les candidats qui
gêne ici via se présenter une question
venant d'un autre candidat une et un
autre candidat vous a posé une question
on va donc découvrir quel candidat vous
allez c'est une question et après je
vous laisse y répondre cher jean
lassalle a ainsi tué au second tour je
te soutiens d'arrêt alors si je suis au
second tour est ce que tu me soutiens je
ne peux pas te répondre
moi je te remercie d'abord pour
la confiance mais je crois que une
élection aussi importante que la nôtre
comme porte deux étapes sur le suivre
des institutions françaises et je convie
fonkam se raccrocher à ce qui est écrit
et ce qui est le plus fort dans le
marais dans l'agression des français il
ya un premier tour et a cité un second
tour donc tout cela mais de langue là
que je respecte ce que tu fais mais je
ne peux pas répondre à ta question on va
passer à la halle à passer à la question
suivante
et pour ça je voulais s'appuyer sur ce
deux heures de
délai entre le moment où la vie' nouveau
cinq ans à ralentir l'an l'occurrence
c'est un des mots j j'espère que vous
connaissez l'émission le juste prix mais
là ça être le juste chiffres
concrètement je vous posais une question
qui concerne les jeunes et là l'objectif
n'est pas de vous donner enfin lilian
fait l'idée c'est de mieux comprendre
concrètement quels et quelles sont les
mesures de votre programme on va
afficher du coup la question je voulais
essayer répondre apprendre à parler
d'autres programmes en quelle année le
service militaire at il été supprimés ce
que ces 91 95 97 ou 2002 je pense que
c'est
jacques chirac alors la petite ferme 95
ou
1,97
je pencherais plutôt pour
il apparaît là qu est ce qu il avait
déjà mis un terme je pense peut-être 95
à peu son attaque sur alors la chine est
pas qu un jour je perds je le dis créé
en tant que tel qui met fin au service
militaire il est entré en vigueur en
2002 c'était devenu plus allawi tarder
non mais il avait posté via il avait
annoncé plus tôt il avait annoncé plus
tôt pourquoi est-ce que je pose la
question là c'est pas en soi pour jouer
à un quizz là dessus c'est pour aborder
un sujet puisque le service militaire
vous êtes favorable à son retour pas
sous la forme forcément tel qu'on
l'avait jusqu'ici mais une forme
différente vous parler notamment de
service national civil ou militaire est
ce que vous pouvez dire concrètement en
quoi ça consiste pour les jeunes qui
regarde cette vidéo je voudrais vraiment
réussir à le dire tel que je le pense là
je pense pas aux juges militaires de
papillon ou au même de quelques papas
record qu'ils ont fait mais je pense à
ce registre et actuel très modernes
qui permettent à une tranche de jeunesse
sept cent mille jeunes parents de se
retrouver à 18 ans obligatoirement c'est
ouvrir obligatoires du 20 septembre vge
ceux qui sont dressés par l'organisation
de l'armée de la défense en france il
remplit tous vers les armées
où iront découvrir des services auxquels
quand ils ont entendu parler mais je
pense au confessionnal je pensais aussi
peut-être la recherche notamment la
recherche spatiale avec c'est halloween
pourront ils sont préqualifiés les
militaires civique dans les hôpitaux
dans la reconstruction de village il ya
tellement besoin demandeur à leur
collection de fermes agricoles et vous
parlez de mandeure et c'est à dire que
c'est un service militaire qui est
rémunérée si oui comment combien comment
ça se passe pour les jeunes
je ne leur donnerai pas beaucoup parce
que je considère que c'est un service
national
donc je n'ai pas fini de calais autant
le dire le taux mais il faut quand même
que le jeune homme et sa famille qui
souvent ne sont pas les récents 10 % des
français
sont pratiquement au seuil de deux
difficultés financières mais je crois
que quelque chose qui ressemblerait à
ces singes euros par mois voilà ce que
s'ils jouent les 500 euros pour
commencer peu 500 euros pour viser c'est
un service à saisir un arbre après je
mettrai le rs1 qui n'est réservé qu'à
quelques heures aujourd'hui et que je
n'agirais beaucoup plus pour le porter à
800 euros par mois et je donnerai
l'autre je donnerai la possibilité à
tous les français de faire l'amour en
garantie par l'état de 20 millions de 20
millions ce serait les millions d'euros
mais d'un nouveau service celui de 20000
au vélo
parce que je vois toutes ces chiffres
donc des mille euros c'est bien de 2000
euros et sinon pour revenir mais il ya
aussi vite et aussi de passer tous les
permis de conduire leur éclat de ce
service national civique ou militaires
ensuite il ya la possibilité pour ceux
qui le veulent de donner des cours à
ceux qui veulent bien recevoir pour
faire du rattrapage ils auront la
première
annuités de retraite la plus difficile à
obtenir
certains des contrats comme une annuités
de retraite oui c'est à dire c'est pas
mal déjà ça et enfin ils ont la
possibilité d'échanger leur giro chis et
leur creux de mail c'est à dire que
c'est toute une génération
composée de garçons se fit deux lignes
de lourdios ichère france irait voir
pendant un an des merveilleux bout de
france de la martinique ou ailleurs qui
vont se retrouver moi je ne vois pas
comment compte tenu des disparités qui
se sont établis on peut faire des
nations autrement on va passer à une
dernière dernière question je voulais
s'appuyer sur l'action de buzzer depuis
donc le
[Musique]
voici le drapeau français d'art c'était
moggi vous allez découvrir des phrases
en fait une reprise plutôt une phrase
assez célèbre qui est a été prononcé par
françois hollande c'est en 2012 face à
nicolas sarkozy c'était le fameux mois
président là en l'occurrence vous allez
pouvoir le reprendre un petit peu à
votre sauce puisque vous allez voir
affichées à l'écran des phrases vous
propose de lire chaque début de phrase
est de compléter en une phrase chacune
des chacun des éléments qui vont
s'afficher pareil pour mieux comprendre
votre vision de la france est ce que
vous me permettrez de dire ah bah je
n'ai pas de cette nouvelle et voilà que
j'avais n'avait pas du tout aimé cette
expression de france à lens domino -
président moi je me dirai jamais ça et
on me dit hier
je dirais je paie ma vision de la france
ma vision oui la vie dure
ma manière de servir le pays
comme vous me l'avez demandé très lent
alors on va voir du coup et que là les
questions ici donc on va pas dire bah
président réservé à jean lassalle ma
manière de servir le dans ma manière de
servir le pays au monde le pays je vais
arriver mon ennemi ce sera bon je ne me
reconnais pas vraiment de mai mais parce
que l'ennemi
vous pousse à la guerre je dirais que la
partie en une phrase social jeu pourrait
définir comme celle dont je le fais de
plus encore une fois c'est cette
financiarisation financiarisation de
l'économie et donateurs pénétration
prochaine question pour servir le pays
ma première visite officielle sera sera
peut-être à paris je ferai peut-être
tour de paris pour bien rendre compte
des différentes strates de paris ce
travail sera pas l écrivain dieu
d'étrangers on est plus gros plus
personne donc par qui je commencerais
nerveux travail à faire le suivant -
président si j'étais élue j'habiterai
alizés votre barre à l'elysée à l'elysée
parce que ce jeu suit quotidien que
c'est la résidence de prison et sa femme
et si un enfant qui va venir je ne sais
pas je suis votre chargeur faire
peut-être mais moi j'essaie d'aller
acheter selon
un autre mon premier ministre sera celui
qui aura le plus à gagner et le plus
voulu à mes côtés ou jeu serge
c'est-à-dire s'agir l'un de vos proches
l'un de l'autre
vous ça ira c'est pas ça fait percevoir
sens et par sens elle ne connaît pas
tous deux sur le système c'est ça qui
est magnifique dans ma vie chère de
pommes des jeunes qui va me voir où je
t'aime ça c'est possible on a beaucoup
qui regarde c'est donc dans ce code
c'est un moment donné c'est ça que la
politique et honneur vous ne savez pas
l'espace d'avant que vous pouvez vous
affirmer par votre voix ce que mick et
là je savais qu'il allait pouvoir
trouver la force de pour la sixtine etc
il faut faire confiance je sers
confiance et puis d'une certaine manière
moi je crois au destin
ce sera le dernier maintenant -
président la france sera alors en une
phrase pour terminer beaucoup plus
souveraine ça va prendre des décisions
qui s'imposent de voir l'inter de
défense et puis pour trouver un fait la
nouvelle énergie
de demain qui doit durer 30 40 ans et
plus et pour moi c'est l'énergie solaire
avec un exemple afin
que nous louons général de gaulle qui
est extraordinaire et l'énergie des
marées à ceux ci nous réglons le
problème de l'énergie après les
milliardaires ils peuvent continuer
c'est les jeux d or et 1 milliard je
leur dirai qu'ils ne vont pas partir
même temps
merci merci dans ce vent ou
s'entretueront le joug tout cas vrai
merci beaucoup tu peux devenir un héros
pour la france même s'est installé au
panthéon merci jean lassalle pour votre
temps d'avoir accepté encore une fois
cette interview que l'on fait avec tous
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
pour en savoir plus sur votre programme
et je précise d'ailleurs que cette
interview vient en complément d'une
autre vidéo qu'on fait là aussi avec
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
c'est une vidéo qui va présenter votre
programme est votre vision de la france
en une dizaine de minutes une vidéo qui
sortira sur cette même chaîne youtube a
d'ailleurs j'en profite à dire du coup
pour ceux qui nous regardent n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à cette chaîne
youtube je ne sais pas encore le cas
pour ne pas louper les interviews
suivante de tous les candidats vous
allez donc à voir aussi les décryptages
et les programmes et les interviews qui
vont arriver dans les prochains jours
sur cette chaîne encore merci jean
lassalle pour merci infiniment
hugo et merci hugo décrypte chez adoré
ce studio parce que il est dépouillé
mais y ait un peu habité par la
réflexion de tous ceux qui vont précéder
le tout suivant est la vôtre qui n'est
pas rien et de l'équipe qui veulent un
retour merci merci à vous et prenez soin
de vous on se dit ah très vite après but